we're almost done and you know what that
means it's time for the doggy bag
there he goes
and today it's a book that i simply
can't put down the anthropocene reviewed
by john green it's on all the bestseller
lists and i actually got to interview
him um when i co-hosted cbs this morning
and that was what turned me on to the
book
it's so fun now anthropocene is how our
human actions impact the planet but
don't think that it's a downer of a book
it's actually the exact opposite it's
john green's take um on all these
different things he's experienced in
life and it's full of nostalgia
and cute charming stories and wisdoms
and he actually gives
all of these things in life uh a
five-star review um so they each chapter
ends in this really cute way like how
many stars is he gonna give a certain
thing um i i love this book i'm going to
steal this one that copies for you roxy
drew all right well thank you so much
everybody for coming today
[Applause]
have a fantastic day we hope you take
this
[Music]
you